c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche
comment ça s'appelle votre numéro de
téléphone
t o n
plus loin n une eau voilà atout numéro 1
pour ton combat là ça va bien se passer
parce que c'est compliqué d'être aimé
excuse moi de te déranger je suis
nouveau ville tu peut m'indiquer le
chemin pour aller dans ton appart
de plus avec débiteur jean-michel mettre
tous mes boules ou alors que tu me
réponds bah écoute là t'es tu es bien tu
es sur l'avenue de la croche pourri que
tu continues forcément tu seras sur la
rue du râteau je te propose les
premières à droite non écoute ça c'est
l'impasse et bien comme cette
conversation est magnifique et vous
sentez bon patchouli à tunis une vanne
c'est avant tout un rire julien de
l'adar cas comme vous dites ici et pour
le très célèbre écrivain canadien pierre
fillon le rire dilate l'esprit pour le
célèbre humaniste brivistes acquis a dit
on a retiré deux chevreuils plutôt leur
idylle à 10 mois jolie gazelle tu dois
vraiment être essoufflée la force de
trotter dans ma tête
j'adore
vers onze heures tu trembles dans ma
tête j'espère que c'est du pied gauche
parce que ça porte bonheur
franchement mademoiselle de toutes les
lettres de l'alphabet c'est ton cul que
je préfère
c'est un revenu qui parle de télé c'est
vous c'est moi parce que quand je te
vois je pense à deux lettres
le gie élevé quand je te vois tu me fais
penser à un kiss cool tu es super
fraîche et tuchan grave bon ça c'est
marrant parce que je tue me fait plutôt
penser un beignet aux sucres super
collomb était grave lourd
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]